this is great I've always wanted to do
this I never really get to talk to like
another guy on an instrument what do you
say we get into one let's let's do it
why don't you show me a little happy
fuse go so the first song I'm gonna lean
down a little bit so you can see I'm
starting to lighting is crappy I think
people can use their imagination with
what my face really looks like what's
great about writing for narrative is
that you have parameters you kind of get
to paint-by-numbers and it's why I've
written more songs in this past year
than I have my entire career simply
because again writing for narrative has
a vehicle behind it if you're writing
for yourself and you're putting your
your soul on the chopping block it's a
very different thing and I admire so
many people that do people like Rufus
Wainwright that really make themselves
in their lives vulnerable because I
don't have that what's nice about
writing a show like royalties as you go
okay we have all these episodes here is
the joke for each episode here is the
kind of character we might want to have
doing that song so that kind of lends
itself to what kind of genre you might
want to have and then and this is this
is all before one of these people were
cast so we don't know how it's gonna be
sung at all you just know that I at
least I did I was very specific about
curating different genres for each thing
and I haven't seen the entire show but I
didn't want any song to be similar to
the other so I kind of had this you know
check the checklist that there has to be
like a class of canna ballad there has
to be like a hard legitimate like
hip-hop song I want like if if it's
gonna be a pop song it has to be on this
side of pop or if it's gonna be anything
remotely reggaeton it has to be over
here so what's fun about that is given
the each each joke kind of lended itself
to the kind of genre so the first song
was a song where the our heroes
basically write a song a love song that
is inspired by just being really hungry
and and basically being in love with a
hot dog and using all that imagery and
words that would describe being in love
with something so much that you would
move a mountain or kill a man because it
is just that good and that's the end of
song just
good one of my favorite songs ever is a
Cole Porter song where he would write
out phrases and without writing the
notes he would write out how you would
say at the natural rise and fall of
stuff and so an example a great example
that is it was just one of those things
if the song doesn't go whether he goes
it was just one of those things and it's
very conversational in the rise and fall
of it goes how it goes the example I
just gave us a bad example because I
didn't invert the rise and fall of the
words so but you see what I did one of
the things yeah what the Cole Porter's
version is better so when I'm saying so
just that good I immediately set that
piano as soon as they had that line you
know and well cuz you know if you're
just that good you're just sick here's
your judge good yeah you just so you
know one having a deceptive cadence here
to the minor six yeah in order to turn
back around to the affirmation of Dan
you're not you're only just that good
you just one of my favorite tricks which
is the minor form v I love them too
minor flick here you know that's a flat
[Music]
yeah but the five being that B flat in
the bass but having an A flat minor
chord I wanted that to be the the
refrain so to speak but the the thing
that I came around to that I really
liked was the idea of writer is trying
to figure out how to play like what is
the thing you can play with with those
three words and I liked that there's
this internal thing of it's just that
you're just that good and having writers
realize that so that's in the episode
where they figure that out so the only
way that I could have that
realization happen is I kind of wanted
the sort of tag of the there's no real
chorus I guess it's just a tag and then
the refrain is that he's on the back
half sort of like you know Hey Jude
I had this descending thing it's again
so you have to figure out a musical way
to lift the way you would say it's just
that you're just that you're just that
good and so figuring out a way to chord
wise cordially
what's the matter verb quarterly do that
it's hard to explain think of your
musician but just that sort of
descending you know you know picked up a
few tricks from the Randy Newman slash
James Taylor's that was one of those
magical moments
they said the song is just that good and
I immediately just said just it's so
wonderful and it's so cool that you can
sneak these like chord progressions into
very catchy very accessible pop tunes
well thank you the idea is to kind of
bait-and-switch people with this joke
you know that's what's so fun about
musical comedy in general is that you
can slip in things that you know like
the best example I always say you know
thing that really raised me is you know
the Disney Renaissance and people like
Ellen Macon and Howard Ashman that you
know were what they're doing isn't like
hyper sophisticated it's accessible
sophistication that that sticks with you
it just cuts to the [ __ ] jug like the
center of your heart and in ways that
you can't really explain it's it's it's
a little more heady
lyrically than
hot music but it's accessible for people
that love pop music but they service you
know they still service a story and a
sort of heightened way of talking now
I'm not singing on that level because
we're spreading a song about a hot dog
but there are things in there that yeah
I really like the bait-and-switch of
like okay we're the joke is this stupid
so it's gonna give us this much license
to be somewhat somewhat sophisticated
just to kind of level it out you know
and I think we do that with a lot of the
other songs where you know even break it
in which is a full-on hip-hop song that
is sort of Mickey Mouse intoxicated a
through a sound that might otherwise be
more associated with that very concept
so and that's a broad generalization I'm
speaking and huge broad swaths there but
yeah it's it's fun like if you have this
song from a person that you think that
your brain tells you is gonna be like
this then you have what he's saying be
the opposite of that to sort of let the
two things balance each other out so
that's something that I always like
doing with with everything I do you know
if it's gonna be funny make it really
poignant or if it's gonna be poignant
with a lot of gravitas and make it
really funny
it's gonna be heartbreaking you know
make it cathartic you know there's
things that have to kind of balance each
other out to justify their presence
when did music first kind of like come
into your life I know it's been a huge
part of your career since the days of
like Starkid yeah of course I mean if
music has always been sort of an
integral part of my experience with life
for reasons beyond my knowledge I can't
really point to any one moment but when
I was five I just told my mom that I
wanted to play the violin I can't point
to any example of like who was playing a
violin I just said it and you know
children just say a lot of stuff and God
blessed my mom and God lost my parents
for being like okay cool let's sign you
up like immediately and
I get in the more I know people with
children it's like wow that was like a
really incredible instinct of my parents
just immediately go for it and I owe my
entire musical ability to you know years
and years of violin training I studied
with a wonderful school in San Francisco
the Oakley violin studio where I was a
Suzuki student for anybody that's ever
studied Suzuki it's kind of its kind of
like a Jedi Order of a specific way of
learning whether it's just my own
inclination and ability as a musician or
if it was that specific methodology I
don't know I think was a healthy
combination of both but yeah I think the
the violin also has such a small margin
of error that it really kind of honed in
a way that I don't think I was ever
aware of toes older this sense of
specificity and dynamics and it really
honed ear training I've always been more
of an aural person anyway it's certainly
been very useful in my acting career
people always ask the question you know
what do you consider yourself more of a
musician or an actor and I always saved
it both the same thing music is acting
acting it's music it's cadence its
rhythm it's it's again dynamics
crescendos D crescendos timing you know
there's just like a Bach cantata there's
like a million different ways to perform
that line so to speak and yet there are
so many you know versions whether it's
you know there's a difference when yo-yo
mob playing how Elliott Gould plays it
it's like you know there's so much
variation and and personality that can
be in vibed into things and so if you
can't tell by the way I'm sort of
thinking about it that sort of approach
to looking at anything holistically I
think came from studying the violin for
so long and if it wasn't for that I
don't think I would have been able to
jump into so many other instruments I
think people who aren't musicians are
always fascinated by people who go oh my
god he plays this this and this and if
you meet like a brass player or like a
wooden player it's like he plays the
trombone and the trunk
the French horn like all these things
you're like wow that's amazing like well
because the part of the same family so
for me as a string instrument guy
anything with my fingers
you know piano was a natural byproduct
of that although I never took lessons it
was always around the house so I can
kind of translate what I knew from
violent to the piano and then certainly
and most predominantly through my life I
picked up guitar when I was like 10 and
that kind of became the main instrument
that I would play kind of the rest of my
life I think I play everything else like
a guitar player drums or piano I'm
thinking in terms of guitar chords and
that's why on the piano I have a lousy
left hand because I'm mainly thinking in
terms of my right hands like it's all
this so yeah I mean music has always
really just been the the anchor and so I
never knew how I would incorporate that
into my professional life I was always
in bands and I liked writing songs and I
did I always just I I much like a lot of
artists who had to you know before cut
I'm not saying I'm Picasso by any means
but Picasso spent years you know
painting the Masters works like you'd
copy those works before he did his own
thing so likewise for me I spent years
you know learning and playing covers of
all my favorite 90s alt rock songs and
pop songs that that kind of became its
own education in the way that I would
write my own music or play with other
people but just to tie somewhat of a
poem this whole dossier I'm a musical
background with music you know again it
was always present in a fun way like
again playing in bands and I always
liked doing that I would write songs and
yeah I wanted to be a singer songwriter
but like I'd I kind of I would just do
whatever would whoever would take me as
an aesthetic acting academically at the
University of Michigan I did music on
the side but they were never really
linked and yes I did musical theater in
high school but certainly not in a level
where I thought I would ever do it
professionally I just thought it was
like cool so here I am in the university
mission which actually has a prestigious
musical theater department
that I was Michigan as well what's yeah
how do we not lead with that that's a
fair point fair question I buried the
lead a little you really did that's like
the way in we could have gotten past Wow
okay well then you understand so I was
not in that department and it's a great
music school I took a lot of music
classes there music college and it took
violin lessons and voice lessons there
but I was not in this department so they
were there was kind of like church and
state for the longest time it was like I
would do acting stuff and I would play
music and it wasn't really until my
senior year where my friends who had
done a variety of stupid shows I I was
really involved in basement arts which
was a student group that would just for
shits and giggles you put on plays and
musicals for like a nominal amount of
people usually your friends usually
drunk and usually and always for free
low stakes fun places for students to
just kind of cut their teeth and I spent
a lot of time there as an actor as a
director and my buddies did like a
musical every year like one year they
did The Hobbit they did a children's
version of The Hobbit but they changed
the story to like involved Keebler elves
and they used Celine Dion songs to score
it because that was funny and nobody
would ever see this so our senior year
they did a Harry Potter one and they
asked me to write some songs workers
like oh you write songs and none of the
kids except for two were just theater
kids that didn't do musical theater so
it was kind of this ragtag group of
people that were kind of putting on the
thing that they don't ordinarily do me
included I've like okay I guess I'm
going to write I like writing songs but
never written for like a narrative
specifically before and so once I
started doing that I really realized how
much I liked it how much skills and
proclivities I had as an actor was
really helping out my instincts as a
songwriter and vice versa and so once I
kind of dialed into that I was like this
is this is something that is really
calling to me and then from there on out
I was like I think I like writing songs
for narrative every now and I'll write
for myself but for narrative is really
my thing how did the impetus event
project start well I've always had it in
my head when I was when I started
working on Glee which you know we not
gonna pretend isn't a huge part of this
story again that kind of involved a lot
of things we were saying it was I always
liked
Harrison is you know in Slumdog
Millionaire were all the questions he
was asked had exactly to do with
specific life experiences he had
completely serendipitously that's kind
of what happened with me on Glee I I had
for years been playing songs popular
songs the what I like to call the
contemporary American Songbook because
there's the jazz standard songbook that
if you're went to music school or you're
a music fan like you got to know you
know what you got to know all the
standards I just played that song
completely wrong sorry different case
but there are those standards and then
there are and I think things like Glee
and and and American Idol really
contributed this to the latter half of
the 20th century up to the beginning
Athens 21st century which is the America
the new songs that you have to know if
you don't know don't stop believing if
you don't know piano man if you don't
know how to play what's one you know so
much so that we almost roll our eyes
that when you see somebody go up and
play that open mic he's there now Stan
what's the other standard that I always
say people do now oh you always see
young girls do like these are the ones
you gotta know so I spent so much time
in bars and restaurants both in college
in Michigan State Street at Savas and I
had taught delis I played there a lot
when I moved to Los Angeles I played at
Maggiano's twice a week and I would play
these long four or five hour sets where
my whole rule was never to play the same
song twice so I'd be playing all these
hits that are popular popular songs that
I didn't write that I just knew the
chords I knew them I just knew all of it
and then I joined the show where I sing
popular hits from the new American
Songbook and I was like I I cannot think
of a person who's more built for this so
that's not what you asked but during
that time I signed with Columbia Records
because they're like oh wow you have
records that have charted on Billboard
of course there was referring to star
kid and some of my own stuff that I had
put out just as a supplementary source
of any kind and so they're like
oh it's put out a record with you and
that whole slog was really interesting
because I I started navigating the world
of songwriting of what it is to go to
writer sessions producer sessions and
try and create something from nothing
whether it's for myself or other people
you kind of it was it was an
infrastructure that was so ripe for a
comedic series to me because it is this
comedy of errors where you meet these
relative strangers and you go okay how
do you feel I'm kind of mad you know my
breakfast was cold today and you just go
okay we're going with that let's change
the words - like mockery my soul is and
I'm like you kind of piece these weird
things slowly together out of nothing
and sometimes it is the Carole King
musical beautiful were these beautiful
life moments inspire these extraordinary
albums that change the face of culture
but that is the minority of the time
those are the one in a million you know
Carole King is an outlier where most of
the people who write songs for a living
there's almost utilitarian value so we
got to get it placed for this album if
we're lucky for this artist trying to
get it in place for this commercial
we're trying to get this sink I got to
pay my bills that would be a huge
paycheck you know there are things where
it's a little less sexy and more like a
nine-to-five slog and I was always so
enchanted by this separation of people
don't know music thinking that it's an
amazing romantic thing where they write
the song that I'm gonna play at my
wedding and like guys in a room just
banging their heads against the wall
just dying to find like ice prime that
isn't that shitty so I've always really
been in love with that and everybody in
the music industry especially
songwriting has great war stories from
artists or producers and again it just
seems so ripe and I always loved these
music shows like you know insider shows
like Empire and Nashville and smash
which all look at the music industry in
very different ways but do it with a
really big sense of melodrama melodrama
yeah
and I being a goofy person
really kind of gravitated more towards
the scrappier goofier satirical side
where we didn't take it seriously at all
but still treat it with enough knowledge
and respect that you know it was
somewhat believable and I kind of wanted
to I always said what Rio nine-one-one
is the cops I kind of wanted to be for
music shows I wanted to have credible
legitimate you know people working on it
from the music front via connections I
had made being the via those years I had
with Columbia Records and working on
Glee but still doing what I think I do
best with my friends from college which
is just taking the piss out of something
we love
so it took years when I finally had the
time to do it but it it was just always
swimming in my head I always want to
make the show I wanted to make the star
kid people and I instead of acting and
one thing and writing music for another
thing I wanted to do it all in one thing
so again I'm really one with for the
long form answers man you got to be
careful cuz I'll go on yeah we
appreciate it
there's so many wonderful guest stars on
this show
Rufus little RAL singing to breakin in
tune the one that like really captured
me the most was Mark Hamill as this
country legend his performance is so
like interior and so lived in an
authentic what was it like working with
him and writing for him there's a lot of
things I'd like to say about Mark Hamill
that we don't have enough time to talk
about but as an actor think yes of
course he's part of one of the biggest
cultural phenomenons of all time and and
owns up to that and loves that and is
and is a American treasure for for that
international treasure for God forgot
sake but another thing that I think
people might not realize is that he's a
tremendous actor he's an actor he was
acting when he played Luke and as he's
shown through his very sort of prolific
voiceover work for the past forty some
odd years the he is a vocalist in the
true sense of vocal manipulation and
he's a true character actor if people
were familiar with his other work beyond
Luke Skywalker
he's a litany of really amazing
character II things as a lot to do with
changing his voice and the way he talks
and um and he's really good at it it's
not like he was doing that
specifically break away from Luke
Skywalker it's because he just is a
naturally gifted character actor and
performer getting him to do this was a
total shot in the dark and him saying
yes was a total surprise I encouraged
all of them to do to create their own
character and be their own thing and
because it was a country song he
obviously came in with this kind of
southern drawl like you know Johnny Cash
meets I don't know if Bruce Springsteen
was more of like a straight-up
country-western guy and he was really
worried about coming into the booth and
you know getting to produce local
produce Mark Hamill is a feather in my
cap that I never thought that I would
ever have he he was excellent because he
gets vocality and he gets the joke
because he's a funny guy so if you get
those two things that's kind of all you
can really ask for you know I wrote the
song I think I want to say like six
seven six semitones higher so we had to
make it low for him obviously because
he's got this low rough Rumble which
serviced the character really really
great he was really great with the
accent and he was great in the booth and
the funniest thing that I like to say is
I kept trying to get him to say the word
penis like five million times that I
kept saying all right mark I need like I
need like a a harder previous I need you
to really rip into that consonant so
it's really funny
give me an literally saying to mark
hamill and him and I laughing going I
need you I need you to give me a harder
penis mark hamill and having that
actually not be a joke but an actual
direction that had value to the song is
just I mean the joke explains itself but
for that one Nick Lang who is Nick and
Matt who the brothers that I wrote the
show with Nick doesn't fancy himself a
songwriter but they're comedians and so
they are naturally gifted when we wrote
the song we kind of had this like how do
we connect this really silly monologue
about this guy finding solace on the
side and the proportional presumed sides
of King Kong's penis to with how do I
make that an empowering anthem and so we
were trying to like follow the the the
structure of country songs it has to be
a story in which you find comfort so we
kind of thought about what is
or he was you know he's he got to New
York City and he he tried to live his
big dreams and everybody laughed at him
and and and he had to do XY and Z to
feel better than everybody to be clear
this is literally about the character
King exactly he got to New York City
he had judge this is detuned you just
arrived he was hungry he was naked he
was barely alive so that was like how we
started the song me and Nick just
talking about it and then Matt rad and
Chris Wallace and Joshua brought the
song with a bunch of guys sitting around
making King King Kong jokes it kind of
formulated into what it was but the idea
was to make it an empowering country
album but it was all red and before we
knew was gonna be Mark Hamill so luckily
you know nowadays with technology you
can just pump things down I'll probably
release it at some point but I and my
original you know I did original demos
and all of the song and if you heard him
you wouldn't ever believe that like if
you heard he wouldn't go oh yeah we
should have Mark Hamill sing that song
it wouldn't have occurred to anybody but
I'm but I'm glad that it ended up that
way because they're very different and
it's such an awesome story why don't you
take us home less than we do you want to
walk me through that course I mean it's
a very simple song I mean I listen to a
lot of I forget all their names there's
a lot of country artists that I was
listening to for inspiration but uh just
uh if we're in the key of D it's just a
four one five six so that's GD a B minor
is the verses you got to New York City
oh we don't we're doing the chorus right
yeah whatever you want yeah so it's just
arrived he was hungry he was naked he
was barely alive try to make a big show
biz showed him what he had but they all
just laughed in his face back to the
five so that's the verses are well just
do the pre-chorus and we'll do the
bridge really quick yeah we have the the
minor six o G minor and I think of my
friend every a minor every time
excuse me a seven time
feel small he never laid his tiny penis
make him forget he was the greatest of
all and the reason I was so keen on him
saying that is because up until that
point of the song it sounds like a very
earnest story so I was like when you say
that word it has to shatter through the
screen of somebody watching where they
go wait what are you kidding me so that
was like the intent behind when he song
that that's that was the direction so of
course we come in on to then walk down
to the B matter into the e minor no no
in your my day walk up to the G so we
don't have enough time to go this river
but yeah yeah that was that was a lot of
fun too right and what can I say I love
that song I just I still can't believe
in every interview I talk about it that
Mark Hamill's Negin just close behind I
know Mark Hamill sing it and you wrote
it and that that big hit and that E
minor is so fun and so satisfying every
dude I mean every like we don't even
have time to talk about this but just
the strength of every genre this
especially if you grew up in the 90s
it's a big one
anything that resolves from a you know
what is that the the three was it so
we're doing for indeed so oh it's a two
to the two walks up to the four guitar
was June it's the best way to tag
something I'm
careful what I say next cuz I could talk
about this for hours and hours and hours
clearly but I apparently gotta go talk
to other people so can i Darren thank
you so much freaking out about music
theory talking about - yeah what else is
there to do like what more could I want
Thanks please watch it guys thanks
[Music]